so we have a panel titled the imperative
of energy humanities where energy
engineering and the arts intersect and
I'd like to introduce to you our
professor Cathy Newman
she's an associate professor of English
at Carnegie Mellon University she'll be
moderating our panel today good morning
I'm Kathy Newman I'm faculty in the
English department and I'm gonna
introduce the panel I think they're
gonna sit here and we're gonna take
turns giving some short presentations
Jacob gesslin is a PhD candidate in
literary and cultural studies his
research focuses on 20th and 21st
century American culture and cultures of
energy in his dissertation Jacob
examines literary and visual art that
represents her uses coal waste such as
slurry ash and acid mine drainage to
call attention to environmental
conditions in the history of coal and
Appalachia Abigail E Owen is a historian
of science technology and environment at
CMU she teaches history courses about
the social and political aspects of
water and agriculture and a course
called introduction to environmental
ideas for CMU's minor and environmental
and sustainability studies she is
director of education for the
steinbrenner Institute for environmental
education and research at Carnegie
Mellon University Noah throat is an
assistant professor of anthropology in
the CMU Department of History he holds a
PhD from the University of
wisconsin-madison and he's conducted
extensive ethnographic research in the
Philippines his scholarship and teaching
combined the tools of history
anthropology political and political
ecology to ask how relationships with
the environment are shaped both by
uneven relations of power and by
different ways of knowing valuing and
being in the world my work in the
English department deals with labor
culture material history I'm finishing a
book right now called how the 50s worked
mass culture in the decade the unions
made and I'm curating an art exhibit
that opens today
at 200 art that considers the
relationship between capitalism and
culture recognizing the fact that Karl
Marx turns 200 in May of this year so my
presentation asked about the
relationship between culture and energy
what is the history of how we have
cooked our food heated our living spaces
lit up our nights and produced things
that we can enjoy from a cultural point
of view as I began to work at the
intersection of this nexus culture and
energy I've become convinced that energy
history must become an integral part of
cultural studies we can't make or enjoy
culture without energy and at the same
time the kinds of culture we produce and
enjoy are dependent upon the available
energy forms at a given moment I want to
start with this very old example
archaeological evidence for the earliest
evidence of cooking with fire has been
traced to the Wunder work cave in South
Africa nearly 1 million years ago this
means that for the first 996 thousand
years of human life the primary fuel for
heating and cooking and the primary form
of energy for creating light in the dark
has been light from a fire or a few
thousand years later light from candles
and oil lamps is it any wonder that the
earliest forms of storytelling were epic
songs poems and dances told and
performed around an open fire quite
often when energy is defined in the
modern era we think in terms of fossil
fuels coal oil and natural gas
so I'm arguing today that if we're going
to think about culture and energy across
time we must broaden the range of what
we think of as energy and so here are
the categories I want to sort of briefly
introduce before we move to our panel
energy for light energy for heat energy
for cooking energy for transportation
energy for industry and energy for
electricity so my second argument is
that all forms of culture require energy
for their production dissemination and
consumption to create books we need heat
light today a computer we need the
energy that fuels the factory that makes
paper prints the words and binds the
book we also need the energy that fuels
the shipping of the book and we need
heat and light to make ourselves
comfortable while we read my third
argument is that culture is often
engaged in the project of representation
of telling stories about forms of energy
many of our folktales for example take
place in the woods where for nearly a
million years humans had to forge for
their most important form of fuel
firewood so I'm just gonna zoom us
through some of the history connected to
these different forms in 70,000 beef see
we see the invention of the primitive
oil lamp that was usually burned made of
stone and burnt animal fat 29,000 BC we
have the earliest Earth ovens 8,000 BC
we have the earliest evidence of the
pressing and use of olive oil which was
used for cooking and lighting 3,500 BC
the first domestication of horses and
the invention of the wheel 3000 BC we
have the earliest known sailing vessels
2000 RBC is the we find that the Chinese
were the first to use coal as an energy
source by 1300 BC it is common for homes
in Greece to have a central hearth and
here is a Turkish king who installed
radiant heating in his castle 500 to 200
BC we have developments in lamp and
candle making 200 BC Europeans harness
water energy to power mills
in the 10th century windmills were used
in in Persia and in the early 1400s the
first cast-iron stoves in 1400s the
first chimneys 1590s
the mastery of windmills by the Dutch
1600s
the use of coal coke in England so this
really marks a break I want to point out
that for most of human history firewood
an animal fat olive oil were the primary
things that were used to heat and light
and so 1600 1700s is the big break with
coal
there's the increasing reliance on whale
oil and lamps in this period coal
becomes the dominant energy source
17:12 we have the steam engine which
allows us to pump water out of coal
mines which increases the extent to
which we can mine and use coal 17:48 the
first commercially produced coal in
Richmond Virginia and this is coal Hill
in Pittsburgh what does coal hill called
today who knows Mount Washington 1790s
the beginning of gaslights a steam
engine was invented that because you
could be used to heat homes 1821 first
natural gas well in the US 1825 coal
powered trains 1860 the first solar
powered system invented in France 1863
invention of radiators 1870 the early
Standard Oil well 1882 Edison's pearl
street power station 1892 the first
geothermal system built in Boise Idaho
Paris World's Fair features an engine
that can run on peanut oil in 1900 1901
the famous Lucas gusher in Texas 1902
Spindletop Texas this is basically a
year later you can see the growth in oil
production and so really here I just at
the end I want to pause and and wonder
why at the end of the 1400s there's a
printing revolution was this made
possible by advances in the quality of
lamps and oil that gave writers
inventors and printing press operators
enough light and heat to do their work
it admittedly however the increasing
cultural dominance of books Co silence
with the rise in Western technologies to
extract and harness fossil fuels we also
have movable-type invented in China and
here shows the European output of books
by century so again I I think that the
the kind of explosion in book technology
goes with that sea change we see when we
move to coal as our primary fuel and
I'll end with an example of how culture
reflects trends in energy I just want
you to think about all the folktales
that take place in the woods there's a
famous Korean folk tale called the
woodcutter and the fairy a wish-granting
tale the plethora of woods are dangerous
stories from Robin Hood to Little Red
Riding Hood Hansel and Gretel and
Goldilocks the three bears and the most
famous woodcutters in American history
the Tin Woodman and Paul Bunyan so today
please join me in welcoming our panel
that's going to think more about the
connection between culture and energy
Jacob is up next
thank you alright so the short talk that
I'm gonna give today is called energy
waste in the public eye using art as
advocacy and it's part of a dissertation
that I'm working on that looks at
various ways in which literary and
visual arts talk about coal waste use or
represent substances like slurry ash and
acid mine drainage as a way of kind of
thinking about the invite contemporary
environmental issues related to coal so
to say a bit more about just kind of
where this project is coming from and
thinking about the way that we kind of
think about climate change in culture
I've noticed two main tendencies and how
we how we talk about these things so the
first is - there's a tendency to kind of
think in terms of global collectivity
that we all kind of share the same air
we all kind of are going to have to deal
with the similar environmental problems
we all share that same you know planets
finite resources and this kind of
coalesce isn't a concept that geologists
have put forward called the Anthropocene
that kind of takes the recent history or
history of fossil fuel use or just
resource use in general and marks a
geological era where we can actually
kind of
read the human history and the
geological record so there's this one
tendency that Universal eise's then it
kind of competes with a second kind of
or overlapping tendency that looks very
much at the individual so when we think
about the way in which we respond of can
stop everyday folks kind of can respond
to an issue like climate change we think
about our individual choices as far as
what cars we drive what kind of what we
buy at the supermarket it kind of takes
out you know this global problem and
turns it into something that's very much
kind of something that we can see and in
daily life and so there's these two kind
of overlapping tendencies that I've been
thinking through and it then it like
what I've noticed is that there's the
absence of kind of like the way in which
regional histories are kind of specific
areas have their own kind of stories
about kind of fossil fuel use resource
use that are just as much kind of should
be a part of the way that we we think
about these these more global issues in
the present so what I'm going to do is
just kind of talk through a few a few
artworks by one particular artist that
I'm writing about right now this is a
kind of an example that I thought was on
it has a pretty good kind of
illustration of some of the neat kind of
technical techniques that that artists
are using so this is by the artist John
sobral he's a painter from southeast
Ohio and Saburo has worked with an
environmental engineer to develop a
technique where they collect acid mine
drainage out of waterways um kind of
they they look material settle they
spark for certain chemical reactions
that kind of reduce it down to iron
oxide they have purified water that then
they put back into the stream where it
came from and then use the iron oxides
to create pigments that are used in the
art so you can see a little bit just
kind of about the process here and so
what
Saburo has done is he kind of has
developed a a certain technique where he
lays out aluminum discs and then mixes
this
mine drainage based pigments with water
and basically starts to kind of put the
water on like drip the water onto the
aluminum disk to our colors layer and it
creates kind of a bubble of water that
then drives over the course of weeks to
kind of leave this resulting artwork and
so we have an example of this here
there's a way that his art kind of takes
something that we would think of as you
know an environment or that's an
environmental hazard kind of by working
through it kind of you know creates
these images that do have a certain
extent of like kind of a natural beauty
especially kind of in this blues it's
something that is a much more kind of
relatable and how we think about
environmental art you can see here as an
example that's a little bit more cosmic
in its colors okay all right so what I'm
most interested in is how this art on
doesn't just kind of convey an
environmental message you don't get kind
of much meaning by just looking at this
art but instead of interested in how
something like this or a series like
this spark is an entry point into
initiating a larger conversation about
the environment so in this case what you
have is this this art on that sad wall
creates these works of art but also that
these are in the way that he talks about
his art in the way frames is art it's
all about the process that this right
here is just a tool that enables him to
speak more about issues related to acid
mine drainage the ultimate goal that
they're currently working on I think
they have a Kickstarter for this that's
almost funded is basically they're
trying to work to create a large-scale
plant to where they can continue to
produce these paints at a at a at a
commercial level and then use the funds
to further clean up acid mine drainage
sites and things like that so it's it's
the art isn't the kind of the important
thing here it's how it opens up a
conversation
on that note I wanted to include these
images here these don't use the acid
mine drainage pigments but he has
another series where he edges
underground mine tunnels onto onto disks
as a way of kind of getting people to
talk about the way in which we've kind
of recorded history underneath the
surface that way that we kind of have
these these images that are kind of an
artifact of the industrial era that we
that we can talk about so yeah you know
I see this as part of a project that is
both kind of helping us to think through
some of the current environmental
problems that relate are related to
fossil fuel use but also just kind of
ways in which we can think about how
culture can help us to think through
some of the the longer-term ways in
which we've used resources and have
related to energy in in our society
thank you
[Applause]
I'm going to talk about some of the how
and energy humanities I'm a historian
and I'm gonna look at some of the
materials that I can use as a historian
to do the work of energy humanities to
think about humanities and also think
about energy and the science and
engineering of it at the same time and
this is one example of knowing the just
enough about the language of science I
think it's really important to know
what's going on inside the world of
science and engineering not to be a
scientist or an engineer but also to be
able to use that language and to
understand just enough to ask our own
questions our own humanities questions
so for example in this diagram which is
a primary secondary school diagram about
the water cycle we can see that
groundwater is really an important part
of the water cycle understanding some
basic language of basic science of
groundwater can help us to understand a
community's relationship to fracking
when perhaps one neighbor has signed a
contract for fracking on their land and
the other neighbor has not so
understanding those social and political
and rhetorical dynamics at the same time
that we understand the geological basis
for disagreements and arguments another
way that there is intersections between
the work of energy the science and
engineering of energy and humanities is
simply by using maps place and space
images and maps are really important for
my discipline history physical geography
are of course really important for
energy energy resources are situated in
physical geography and the crust of the
earth whether it's coal and oil or shale
or whether it's uranium to propel
nuclear reactors people are also
situated in geography so a historian
like me might ask about those people who
are the workers on the oil rigs who are
the coal miners who are the uranium
miners who are the hydroelectric dam
construction crews and what's involved
for the risks that they take another way
of situating people in place and space
is ethnography so understanding people
in their geographic situation and my
colleague Noah Theriot who's an ethic
just might talk a little bit more about
this the humanities give us a lens to
understand relationships between people
place and space one way to do this is
ethnography so for example I love this
book by Madonna Limbert who's an
anthropologist she went to the Sultanate
of Oman which is in the middle of an oil
boom and she wrote this book the time of
oil and Limbert talks to everyday people
in the Sultanate of Oman to find out how
they understand their relationship to
their new financial circumstances how
their life has changed socially as well
as financially their frontiers and their
education but it also understands
changes their understanding of the
future itself these people understand
everyday people understand that oil is
not forever so that is included in their
understanding of the social and cultural
world around them a textbook I really
like to use in teaching is this history
of engineers I wind up teaching a lot of
Engineers undergraduate engineers in my
courses in history and this author
Jessica Teich tracks the projects and
the mindset of engineers who built
California's infrastructures for water
and mines and dams in the late 19th and
early 20th centuries and the author
tracks those same exact engineers the
same people as they traveled and design
big projects all over the world for
example in Hawaii in South Africa and in
Palestine so this study is about
expertise and the way that experts
assume and implement their authority and
engineering for energy projects but for
engineering students who read this kind
of work they wind up getting some
context for how engineers did their work
in the past and they also get the social
context that made a real difference so
they understand that the social
assumptions the social context created a
lot of the situations where engineers
were asked to solve problems and to
create new energy systems and it leads
to some reflection usually on the part
of those undergraduate engineers about
what they're going to do when they leave
the university and when they become
engineers out in the world one way of
talking about energy being situated in
geography in this case a hydroelectric
dam is that the power of the dam is
related to the power of a river which is
a natural system by studying a river and
by studying the humans who have
historically used lived on taken fish
from and understood the river in
different ways this particular study of
the Columbia River is a classic River
biography there are many River
biographies out there about many
different rivers and it puts dams like
the Grand Coulee Dam and the Bonneville
Dam in social historical and Geographic
perspective sometimes dams create
beautiful archives this film hydro is
part of the huge public excitement about
the construction of dams from 1939 when
people were really excited about
electricity showing up in their homes
and businesses and this dam video is
available on YouTube it was made public
by some wonderful archivists at the
Bonneville Power Administration which is
the administration that still manages
the dams in the Columbia River and this
film hydro is usually apparent to
students who are savvy in the ways of
propaganda and media as a propaganda
film about creating a new energy
installation but at the same time it's
also a very beautiful film it takes
advantage of some of the best and the
Works Progress Administration
film experts and it has a full
orchestral score it's really beautiful
and it's really compelling and it
reminds me of some of the stories that
my own grandmother told me about how
excited she was when electricity came to
her rural home maybe 90 years ago she's
no longer around but I remember her
stories and this this film conveys some
of that excitement um digitized records
are also the work of archivists
archivists do really important work for
historians like me also for
anthropologist and literary and cultural
studies they maintain documents and
materials and we live in this era when a
lot of these archives are beautifully
digitized and available to us who want
to study them without having to travel
and without having to handle the
documents with our own hands so here we
have some beautiful archives with
illustrations of fish and canoes from
the journeys of Lewis and Clark on that
same
Columbia River and then sometimes
archives give you these little gifts
this photo on the left is a photo that I
found when I was doing research on a dam
that was investigated by the World Bank
and they occurred the past director of
the World Bank Robert S McNamara had
visited this dam and I found this
photograph which I thought that was
really beautiful of him overlooking the
dam the rest of the archives of the dam
were quite boring contracts and numbers
and tables and memos that I had a hard
time understanding but then I saw Steven
Spielberg's beautiful movie the post
about a particular moment in 1971 and I
realized that the actor and the costume
designer the set designer had done a
really good job investigating what
exactly Robert S McNamara might have
looked like
dressed like and moved like in that era
so archives because sometimes can give
you gifts like that
[Applause]
good morning everyone
I'm Noah Theriot from the CMU Department
of History and my talk is entitled from
Standing Rock to Susquehanna how the
environmental humanities can illuminate
the politics of energy so thank you all
for coming um I'd like to thank dr.
Newman for organizing the panel the
energy rig organizers for including us
in the lineup and also those whose labor
keeps this campus clean safe and
functioning day in and day out I'd also
like to acknowledge the land on which
we're gathered today for thousands of
years it's been the land of indigenous
peoples including peoples whose names
have been lost a conscious memory as
well as to the Cisco Hannah Kahn nashoni
and other nations at various points in
time today this region remains home to
many indigenous persons from across
Turtle Island and I would like to
express my gratitude to this land and
its indigenous Guardians for the
opportunity to live work and form
kindred here even as I remain an
uninvited guest I wanted to begin today
with a land acknowledgment not only
because it's important to recognize the
settler colonial condition of our
society but also because it helps orient
us to the perspective that the
environmental humanities bring to
conversations about energy my aim today
is to show why we need anthropology
history and philosophy and in particular
why we need the perspectives of
indigenous scholars in these fields if
we want to understand the disputes that
surround energy extraction and transport
in North America today these disputes I
want to suggest are about more than how
the costs and benefits of particular
projects or industries are distributed
and they're about more than climate
change to understand what's at stake and
the seemingly irreconcilable struggles
were seen in places like Standing Rock
to our West and the Susquehanna Valley
to our East
we need to sensitize ourselves to the
historical cultural and ontological
context in which these struggles unfold
let's begin by considering a proposition
that rose to prominence amid the
struggle at Standing Rock water is life
a translation of the Lakota principal
mini which Oni although I cannot speak
for Chet ISA : water protectors or for
any indigenous communities I want to
suggest that water is life is more than
a protest lobe
and more than a truism about the
ubiquity of water as a necessity for
life it's an ontological proposition
about the nature of being and about the
distribution of life or vitality in the
world only when we understand this
proposition as such can we begin to
fully appreciate what's at stake and
resistance to energy projects like the
Dakota access pipeline as everyone here
is surely aware we live in a time of
rapid if volatile expansion of oil and
gas extraction in North America from the
tar sands in Canada to the shale plays
of the u.s. planes in the Northeast
along with this comes an expansion of
associated infrastructures from the
drilling rigs and the pipeline's whose
proliferation over vast areas is
provoking intense controversy to the
adjacent industry is like the ethane
cracker being built about 150 miles to
our east part of what makes these
infrastructures controversial are the
physical risks that they posed the
nearby communities from those living in
the so-called blast though zones to
those whose soil and water may be
contaminated another controversial
aspect of course is the connection to
climate change with many calling for a
scaling down rather than an expansion of
fossil fuel development and yet another
still is the question of property rights
with some landowners angered over the
use of split estates forced cooling
eminent domain and other tactics to
override their dissent these are the
sorts of concerns we are most likely to
encounter in media accounts of what
happened at Standing Rock and all of
these issues over physical security
health regulatory fairness and property
rights should inform our understanding
of what happened there but what many
media accounts and commentaries did not
address is what in my analysis matters
most the long-standing struggle for
indigenous sovereignty in response to
violent colonial occupations and
indigenous conceptions a person had a
kinship and accountability that informed
that struggle in the case of Standing
Rock the Dakota access pipeline was more
than a potentially hazardous
infrastructure project it was the latest
chapter in a long story of dispossession
and forced relocation from the US Army's
1863 master massacre of Sioux persons at
white stone hill to the arm US Army
Corps of Engineers dam projects that
altered sacred rivers and displaced
communities in the 1950s in the words of
olala olala lakota historian LaDonna
allard who founded the sacred stone camp
at Standing Rock quote where the
Cannonball River joins the Missouri
River at the site of our camp today
there used to be a whirlpool that
created large spherical sandstone
formations the stones are not created
anymore ever since the US Army Corps of
Engineers dredged the mouth of the
Cannonball River and flooded the area in
the late 1950s as they finished though
Oh a dam they killed a portion of our
sacred River Potawatomi scholar Kyle Paz
white adds that stopping da PL was about
stopping a vicious pattern of u.s.
colonialism that inflicts immediate
environmental harms and future climate
change impacts on indigenous peoples
unquote so we need to bear in mind the
history behind all of this and that's
obviously something that the humanities
can bring to the table but we also need
to understand what's at stake
ontologically in August 2016
voil Lakota scholar activist I used in
Houston American Horse wrote quote our
elders have told us that if the zoo Zeca
Safi the black snake comes across our
land our world will end
zoos eka has come in the form of the
Dakota access pipeline and so I must
fight unquote his invocation of the
black snake points to the cosmological
and ontological underpinnings of
resistance to the pipeline calling
themselves protectors and not protesters
the resistance bio-jet ISA Cohen and
their allies cannot be reduced to a
defense of nature in the Western sense
of a pristine wilderness nor to a
protection of water as an inanimate
object or resource nor for that matter
to a defense of territory LaDonna brave
will bat brave bowl allard points out
that the pipeline threatened to
desecrate quote places held sacred not
only by the Sioux nations but also by
the ark hara the Mandan and the Northern
Cheyenne unquote this sacredness comes
in part from the inhabitation of these
places by divine beings writing of the
philosophies of Great Plains nations
Blackfeet matey's scholar Rosalind
lapier observes that quote the Blackfeet
viewed water as a distinct place a
sacred place it was the home of divine
beings and defying animals who taught
the Blackfeet religious rituals and
moral restrictions on human behavior it
can in fact be compared to Mount Sinai
of the Old Testament which was
as holy ground and where God gave Moses
the Ten Commandments unquote
but the sacredness also comes from the
role that these places play in
maintaining kin relations that extend
far beyond those one might have with
one's living human kin linking the
standing rock water protectors to the
idol no more and the black lives matter
movement dakota scholar kim tall bear
describes all three of these movements
as having been founded by a quote badass
women who caretake relations unquote the
relation she's referring to our kin
relations but as a dakota scholar she
uses kin in in ways that contradict
patriarchal white settler ideas of
kinship according to in her words the
kin in question are the spirits of
ancestors generations yet to be unborn
and other than human relatives of many
different forms so with all of this in
mind we can understand that resistance
to the pipeline was to a significant
degree about honoring these more than
human kin relations and protecting them
from an existential harm of cosmological
proportions it's worth recalling here
that colonialism is not just a project
of material territorial and ideological
subjugation it's also an ontological and
cosmological project one that seeks to
subjugate and eliminate indigenous
worlds tall bear further writes that in
addition to the genocide of islands that
settler colonialism has affected in
North America quote another eliminatory
tactic has been to sever our sustaining
relations with our other than human
relatives unquote political theorist
Audra Mitchell describes such acts of
severance as transversal violence
suggesting how colonial projects
involved not just physical coercion and
erasure but also the imposition of
colonial temporalities cosmologies and
ontology time being and the cosmos
itself are at stake we can appreciate
then that what was at stake at Standing
Rock was also more than a culturally
significant landscape it was the very
power to determine and enact what
constitutes life elizabeth poe Vannelli
describes this as Gionta power which she
writes operates through the regulation
of the distinction between life and
non-life u.s. settler colonial society
operates according to a secular
biological conception
life and a human Exceptionalist
possessive individualist conception of
personhood to say nothing of the
racialized hetero patriarchal structures
through which these conceptions have
been variegated these conceptions
fundamentally shape how our institutions
function and they fundamentally shape
how we relate to one another to other
than human beings and to the land itself
and these relations are fundamentally
different from those that were being
defended at standing rock life itself is
what's at stake in the politics of
energy today and this is why water is
life is much more than a slogan this is
this challenging proposition but it's
one that the environmental humanities
can help us face thank you I think each
one of you to know your opinion it says
what should scientists and engineers
learn or apply from a humanities
approach
well I would say along the lines of what
I argued in my talk that it's just you
can apply a sensitivity to the fact that
different communities have very
different worldviews oftentimes and not
just in terms of sort of surface level
cultural differences that were that
we're fairly familiar with but sometimes
at the very fundamental level of like
different ontological assumptions about
the composition of reality and the place
of humans or sort of communities of
beings in relation to their landscapes
and to one another so I think it's about
cultural sensitivity and a sense that
what's at stake is not just resources
but sometimes something like more
intangible or difficult to measure say
with the tools of economics or social
sciences for example a hundred years ago
eugenics the science of race and racial
hierarchy was taught in universities as
a real science this was a hundred years
ago and there were engineers who were
doing projects they were implementing
these concepts these social assumptions
at the same time that they were doing
their dam construction or their
community building or sat on that
building and for engineers to learn
about this to learn that a hundred years
ago engineers who were doing good work
solving engineering problems were also
reflecting and using and implementing
these other social ideals is really
powerful for engineers to learn about
and to understand because it makes them
reflect on what might be the social
context what might be the social
assumptions in their own time that they
are reflecting and furthering without
perhaps even realizing it something that
I'd like to add is just I think that
something that the art that I look at it
brings to the table is is a way that
kind of encouraging us to think in a
different time scale
so thinking both at you know we think
often about like what the life of a
certain project might be but something
that I think it's interesting about the
the acid mine drainage project in
particular is how that brings together
you know a century you know at least a
century of resource used in the region
that it's it's something that you know
we see this this art that's based and
based on this substance that's been in
the process of being created for a
hundred years and so in not to mention
coal itself so we have just these ways
in which these kind of objects these
cultural objects can just help us think
more thoroughly about about time yeah I
would add to that an observation about
time I think something that I found
really humbling about thinking about the
timeline of the relationship between
culture and energy is how short the
fossil fuel age has been and while we're
incredibly dependent on these
technologies now most of human history
has been without the kind of resources
we take for granted and that we are
running out of so a lot of our dystopian
narratives imagine a world beyond fossil
fuels like Walking Dead there's not a
lot of electricity and walking dead for
example so I just want us to be humble
in our thinking about what is our right
to these resources and for and that
we've had them for a very short time and
that we may not have them for much
longer it's related to to these how do
we build curriculum to reflect this
philosophy curriculum
I think that providing accessible
historical examples is one way to relate
to humans in the past and see how we
might be doing things differently or the
same right now it's it's a great
awareness builder I think history I'm a
historian of course is is without
parallel in that case so I think that
knowing how we got to where we are and
also being really conscious about where
we're at and what our discussions for
the future are and seeing that in fact
we are embedded in some social
assumptions and some mindsets is really
important I also think that having
language to cross disciplines is part of
this so for Humanities I think having
the language of science as part of our
discussion not to be a scientist is
important and I think the same for
science and engineering having the
language of humanity's understanding
what a close reading is what a critical
reading is what an image analysis is
what is social analysis is I think that
all of this is really important so
getting some of each and each yeah and
on that note I also think that issues
like energy in the environment or
something that you know cuts across
disciplines so well that it's enables
students to kind of not just kind of not
just think about their you know their
immediate work but to how their work
connects to you know range of
disciplines and how they can draw from
that
so in teaching first-year writing
classes based on some of these topics
it's interesting to see folks who you
know might not you know enter it into
the semester wanting to think about
social problems at all
and walk away understanding the way in
which engineering is you know very much
connected to these these decisions we
make as a society as far as how we use
resources so it's it's a way that we can
just kind of as I said have that common
language that we can connect all of
these different approaches to problems
together
yeah yeah and then you know the next
class I'm teaching is on waste and so
you know that's again something that's
very much a cultural object that we see
in our everyday lives that that touches
and touches on designed on on
engineering on you know all of these
kind of problems so it's again this
common symbol this common something that
allows us all to come together to think
about broader environmental issues I'll
just talk very briefly about a class
that I teach called environmental
literature it's a 19th century
literature class and I make the students
go on five nature walks during the
course and that walk has to be at least
an hour and they can't bring technology
on their walk and students have told me
it's the hardest assignment they've ever
been given at Carnegie Mellon so I think
what we're all trying to do is really
kind of peel things back and take
students just kind of remove again some
of the things we've become dependent
upon to think about what what was the
Rose experience and even if we can't
recreate it what would it mean to be
without our technology for an hour thank
you very much to our panelists
fascinating talk thank you
[Applause]